welcome to this video yeah this is again
try to beat the computer computer for
impossible on chess calm let's see how
alifair this time it's um something that
I really don't do that often play the
computer but it it's always challenging
trying to beat the machine so let's see
what I can do
it's 5 minutes and 5 second increments
so it's not a very super quick time
control and I think the some makes some
sense have a little bit of time to to
think ok I go Queen e2 to prevent Bishop
to b5 I have played a quieter opening
here on between Queens pawn game but I
like my position definitely it's um I
have the batch of Bishop d3 which is
nice the bishop on d7 is not doing that
much yeah I'm happy to exchange one
night I have basically have 2 nights
back to him to use those central squares
so I don't mind to trade one of them
the big question is how to proceed I'm
going to retreat this maybe queen d3
provoking and weakness
okay so Queen d3
I probably would just start back to our
six no yeah I think f3 is a move that is
somewhat useful anyway yeah it's use the
king out of this pin yeah so g4 g5 is
this something that helps me probably
not at least not right away but g4
yeah I think I should regroup a little
bit we should back to the three this is
better and so that so that this never
something coming to b5
okay and that Dooley don't mind if he
plays Knight c5 and trades my my bishop
that that in fact would be rather nice
for me okay that's just improve
coordination a little bit and go from
them still I would like to go maybe g4
g5
you know well here he has no ideas to
play Bishop b5 I don't want to oh he's
weakening asking side it is weakening
the King side it's ok b5 before I am
maybe
so it's g4 and so on is this something
that helps me or is it mostly weakening
I mean weakening my own position an
interesting question
I really don't see a way forward without
the move so H for now he cannot take
rook h1 certainly helpful for me
so is retreating so it's g5 something
that is is a good idea I don't know I
think maybe if I put the Queen on e5 I
should try to get the Queen over to them
to the Kings side I wonder if I played
g5 he probably will just play h5
what about f5 is at 5 m f5g takes
definitely definitely nothing great for
me and there's queenie 5 it's not very
logical to trade trade the Queen's I
must admit
I don't know I always oh it's not even
trading so okay going back then but now
g5 yes this is this must be must be good
trying to get get this group on the dark
squares yeah but if I take here King g3
and queen e5 at it it should be it
should be nice for me so take here Queen
takes rook takes okay we all still I go
here and then put the Queen only five
nice playing will give the head
jazz probably wasn't such a brilliant
way to play he's coming or it is coming
very quickly with the pressure on F form
now and I don't want to play ninety two
to protect the sponsors completely now
this is far too passive so what is it
that I should do we need to look you
five something like that
I miss played that I really miss played
that quite considerably
yeah I don't see don't see a great a
great way to play it to me to be
perfectly honest it simply as worse for
me now and it's not a big problem
I mean losing this power is not
necessarily losing the game but I
definitely didn't didn't plan any other
okay
hmm very difficult here I would like to
get rid of one look at least but even
that is difficult to achieve okay cannot
easily play e5 at least maybe I can
prepare before yeah oka for as possible
but at least this puts another pawn on
the light square so I'm just waiting
proceedings not oh how is black going to
try to win this knife the thing is that
I probably with precise play could have
gotten this type of position let's say
without having without being a pawn down
and this is what makes this a little bit
disappointing
this is what I meant with it's not that
track such a big tragedy that a tragedy
that I that I lost this pawn I mean it's
obviously not ideal but that's very
difficult for would like to find a way
forward because of my solid blockade of
if only five I also don't really know
what he should learn maybe with g5
something sometime but we would seem
king maybe over to d6 yeah this is
something that comes to mind but g6 is
also a pawn that requires protection oh
no is now the computer is doing
something maybe 96
ship to d3 night b3 is the point and f3
hangs this might be really a way as a
way to win it
yeah maybe hmm I don't know if I could
have done something against this I don't
know at the end the computer against
control over a 5 this is the big issue
mmm should be three nights B 3 no that's
disappointing
it's that a way to fight now came the
only thing that I see is and this is
even stronger
that's even stronger I thought night c4
we should be 385 and I can at least
sacrifice on e5 yeah this is no lost him
he will get computer will get f3 ok ok
so going for a rematch yeah what was
wrong there exactly with FSF g5 l was
mistimed so here's the next game and
playing black ok of course I want
somewhat close position so d6 was
something like that
what about c5 can i maybe provoke defy
for no I cannot but this is at least
somewhat dry position that seems quite
seems quite easy to play for a human
player
I think success what normally is played
there it's a little bit aggressive
looking but it's not not that bad so we
should do seven I think okay so maybe
just rube see eight playing normal and
all the moves
okay so hmm it's this okay I cannot play
age six if I move the Queen I have no
good square for the Queen hmm yeah this
is a bit of a it's slightly annoying
this situation if I go all night g7 this
may be Queen f4 I cannot play aged six
which is really a shame
hmm I cannot take your fire
and that's surprisingly am difficult
disposition
and this eform for more pressure
I really don't like this position to be
honest oh this I didn't consider at all
but can I go h5 to provoke the straight
this would really help me I mean not in
in a sense that I'm a great shape or
something but at least that feels like
this feels like I shouldn't be shouldn't
be in that bad of a situation before I
still move that is yeah that concerns me
can I go maybe ninety seven Bishop c6
Bishop c6 he can play e5 but this is at
least somewhat yeah somewhat closed
position yeah I don't want that come on
let's let's trade yeah everything yeah
this disputes this fields safe now
that's a quite safe position I believe I
can take now here little take with the
pawn probably yeah but okay I can also
play a strengthening okay
hmm yeah I cannot just take and tonight
the a pond the a porn is is an issue
I don't know here hmm
okay I don't know maybe this is still
okay but it takes root cheeks it is far
too okay it's your computer is not not
winning the porn at least
okay so I'm again relatively satisfied
with this position I still rather yeah
non-technical let's say so weak at his
King side a little bit
what about if I ever systems mmm jinx
he might just take it
I'm not sure about 95 c4 and back white
might play c5 which is not so clear to
me nice if for me that's probably not
helping a lot so what am I doing here
I'm wondering if I should maybe maybe I
should put the rook on the seventh this
is a little bit bad time so that I can
protect the pawn and go from there I
also would like to trade Queens I can
try to offer a queen trade okay
computers not not complying c4 might be
a problem with this diagonal
Jimmy so it's not really clear what what
this accomplishes but it looks looks
active okay so I have provoked this
smoothly I'm I wonder I mean if this is
really any good for for white but I look
hook age falls maybe maybe I should
start with this yeah I blew up lady fire
for mating ideas here okay
yeah there are there are some ideas to
play for made 96 also d5 okay don't you
have cover the back rank here yeah I saw
I saw the idea but it seems that I
didn't do much against it what about if
5v5 takes Queen takes d3 and then what
is six I have the feeling that I really
didn't do a sufficient job to defend
here this D 5 and Queenie 5 it looks
terribly shaky this move actually ok
kake's takes Queenie five I don't know I
have no time just a couple of seconds
okay we got an endgame my king is
relatively quickly
joining which is very important
Wow why this check
King pp7 I don't understand what the
comp is doing for a draw
yeah I wonder it's a bit difficult to
avoid I think a six Kingi four and then
King default looks like playing for a
loss so I'm going to draw this okay
the next game now with wide again let's
see yeah I'm trying again for this Oh
got a Dutch setup interesting hmm
yeah I want a simple position so not not
terribly interested in in g3 kind of
setups maybe I can get an e form Bishop
d3 and d4 I don't know maybe the comp is
playing with g6 you have it I'm ready
for a form okay that's I cancel here
these six if I play a four now if I now
computer will play night before maybe
something along these lines
c3 e5 takes takes e4 it's not really
that great
hmm yeah d6 setup is far better than
let's say something like a stone wall
okay so a night before I was going to
play Queenie juice um well the citizens
I've had
Oh d5 mm-hmm okay but the computer will
manage to play e5 basically yeah
immediately
how it doesn't do that so let's think
about this for a moment
oh my god should be five I'm going to
I'm threatening Bishop takes yeah hidden
he lets me execute that that's nice so
no c3 make sure that no Queen before
business is happening and now let's try
to be precise ninety-five first yes
let's let's start with this would be one
rook f8 f3 this is this is okay it's
their c5 for
counter play yeah well f3 I have to play
anyway computer is not playing c5 okay
so I'm going to push push this rook back
here with g3 King g2 for better control
so yes I'm going to fix this on a light
square
hereafter CD for Queen deform I should
should have a very nice control over
this position
should I go h4 and fYI I can think so
too totally a cement the noid okay look
at you one and ultimately I will double
on the ether exactly now yeah this is
the position that you want against the
machine you are here just better for for
a long-term and computer does not have
any counter play let's think about it I
think rookie 5 intending to play aged 5
is an idea yeah computer addresses that
so still is h5 good maybe I should do
this to prepare h 5 h 5 g 5 this is an
idea
no i can i can improve a little bit more
actually overprotecting f3 ok so
computer has prevented prevented age 5
but in the process has given me has
given me this this further weakness so
I'm thinking maybe I can switch
attention to the a g6 pawn with 95
and now maybe prepare G for the rook G 1
and G form yeah I'm taking with the
Queen okay so he wants a Queen trade um
Knight f3 maybe for the Queen trade also
attacking all kinds of stuff him the
rook on f6 for example okay so we got
the Queen's traded how am i winning this
now maybe a rook rook to d4 to b4 as one
one step and of course I have to get the
King over
I am interesting hmm yeah I don't really
want I don't want to trade and allow him
to take with the Jeep on this is really
what I don't want so I better go back so
that I can take with the night okay rook
to b5 coming hmm yeah I don't want to
trade one f5 so let me do this
regrouping I'm not yet totally sure how
to really break through him it looks
excellent hear that that much is clear
but what exactly is my breakthrough
maybe I have to have to do it like that
controlling everything here and then
ultimately opening up the position with
g-form
maybe something something like that what
I have to avoid is that the bishop is
coming to d3 and possibly to e-form so I
try to avoid this kind of regrouping
okay he had a computer has we grooved to
h3 interesting
okay so maybe yeah I mean Bishop f5 24s
may be on if I put the knight back now
then their sender is rogue at five
mm-hmm very very stubborn defense by by
the comp I don't see a way forward
I really don't ya so computer will come
to your form
but at least at least arm has played b5
is before possible maybe and before ABA
3 and all of a sudden his ribosome is
activating can I also try to prevent
that Ruby can can even even protected
with the rook king deform to achieve
exactly nothing
yeah my book on g5 is not exactly great
I I don't see I don't see a way to to
make anything great happening here to be
perfectly honest maybe when the bishop
was coming over to to f5 like was helped
a little bit too much
and there are there are cases spam yeah
I don't see anything anything active
really
I can shuffle here for ages but compress
very much control still over all of that
maybe a really G for you but at some
some stage a computer has offered to
draw I mean it's still better for white
but I don't really see any way forward
come on
I've lost so many games against this
thing let's do do a third one okay it's
C form how do we do this come on let's
I mean B 6 is not the ideal opening may
be against the machine but it is a
little bit it's very tactical sometimes
but yeah maybe maybe here I'm managing
to yeah okay I know this is not the best
things if you know this line you're
you're aware of that but it leads to
this really closed position
here we go for a closed position I don't
really understand the move to be honest
if I take it what screen b3 is is so so
dangerous
yeah maybe for Bishop c4 no one would
Wow
I mean if I love B takes Queen b3 bishop
see it well yeah there is please see 495
this very very direct attack I come on
okay
I believe this this this machine that I
couldn't take it at least this is a
relatively normal looking position okay
so you form preventing 95 but also
weakening a little bit so if I or not
this is a debatable move but because of
night h4 okay so see four so you know
I'm going to play a fight trying to use
the evil things here we go for the fr at
least I have a very sturdy structure
let's see c5 is really the the thing
that that might be a concern does this
break through but at the moment this is
not directly on chip says it's still not
so easy to to improve from him
mmm yeah I'm concerned still about c5
hmm Jim
Bishop's is 685 so this is not really
really helping me much
I don't really see a great move here I
don't know if just waiting him
maybe the sly fibers coming anyway no
this is coming yeah I saw the idea but I
kind of didn't think that it is so
brilliant if I go look a one and we
trade everything off and I take E for at
the end you know I always see just you
see just playing no computers not doing
that but this is a pawn right isn't this
a pawn
I understand that I'm not easily winning
here or anything but what exactly is so
great about this for the comp I can go
to h7 computer might get d6 here right
if I take C for however what what is the
big idea one check means one check oh I
don't I don't understand really okay
yeah it will just take b6 this is it
that simple so just take it will get B 6
and then the b-pawn is the problem okay
maybe 95 is still ok a checking before
and attacking and 3 so I can take here
so if someone is hanging
yeah it's not easy now Kingi 6b7 er the
two looks
is there some way to get to the king
here for for perpetual the computer will
double definitely if I check on before
what exactly is the move will come to be
7 a.m. and King do 6 I rock a forest and
move I have no check
I have no check whatsoever that's it's
not good
maybe this an Queen b3 checking this
cadets maybe maybe the right idea at
least so if I take now III
Luke f7 is happening him
so maybe age five age form would be
seven now move you up it will play rugby
seven
hmm this is this is the the absolute
nightmare against the compare the pure a
100% purely technical position where you
just calculate and it will out calculate
you yeah maybe there is no offense it's
very much possible Mike will just take
f7 and win them have for him really have
nothing here I can take here but look f7
and it's just lost
yeah it just lost nothing to do him okay
one one more rematch one more image
yeah and the position was was to open
open and computer got b6
unfortunately and then the two ropes
were much stronger than my am then oops
then my my queen so what kind of beam
only here at sea
Bishop d2 but I can play this right
queen bee 693 queen bee - look rugby one
is really bad
what a d3 is hanging
what a silly tech tech yeah but it is
working
Queen 8th but okay wait wait wait wait
there are other moves rook b3 Queen a
six-night 95 23 this is not really great
so okay I can I mean I didn't plan it
here it might be 528 yeah this is this
is still a very dangerous position for
black but it's unfortunately not against
a human but against a computer the compo
defend this mercilessly
intending a five okay I thought this
might help me from structural point of
view maybe I get something back here
should a five what okay so the queen is
going back back to be eight yeah I don't
know it's still some compensation but
what yeah this computer is really
there's no no pain yeah let's weekend
everything if it's not not seeing a
direct refutation its it will play it of
course yeah like II six the King and
everything is totally weak but it's it's
not really measuring that much I have my
my own fair share of of issues as well
and this Queen a for you and for a very
unlucky position of my pieces him
no that's just lost there okay yeah I
can give this check even okay come on
resign this this awful game so one more
rematch
now this yeah and you cannot give up a
pawn against the computer unless your
debt directly winning and then it won't
take it I didn't see that these three
hang so otherwise queen air five is a
total joke this move I can just play
whatever 92 or something okay
so I'm going to play this very solid
Italian game here let's see what the
comp is doing yeah that's not very
exciting 93 okay
that's not a position that I really mind
very much playing it's obviously very
very solid can take also but hmm I
wonder
I can't can also check on f3 let's take
it keep it
the keep it simple way of playing Knight
to d5 yeah okay why not 97 to g6 next
should only protect him
b7 I mean so they take on in three
then FTX would be a little bit a little
bit of a problem so not doing doing that
is he threatening to check or something
like that I don't think so
still hmm how am I playing f7 is is
under pressure
Queen e8 Queen e8 King
King age 7 and then possibly f5 yeah
the computer no f4 is not possible at
least
yeah so let's do that maybe no air form
yeah I am there is brush I know no doubt
this Bishop is just strong and they have
no move for mine I'd really like unites
96 such a computer takes it
this also f5 and threat f5 f6 that even
I mean Rukh the 8 for example f5 is even
stronger than taking on e5 how did I get
into this terrible position really yeah
look the aid and d5 maybe but um this is
this is just a comp we'll probably find
some way to kill me quickly him rukia
one now so that d5 is not easily
playable i cannot even go king f7 young
as f7 is just hanging night c8 yeah sure
d5 is also looking terrible but I don't
know yeah come on try to block this it
is really terrible computer I can take
it and play from here I should be one
Bishop d3 it's I mean really really ugly
look d6 2 is 6
okay so if I take it queen d8 then back
to c6 wow I'm really surprised that I'm
not I mean I'm not saying that I'm alive
but I'm still I'm surprised that the
game is still still going it still feels
relatively solid Queen g5 for further
trades maybe
Bishop b5 maybe but if I play here and
king of âge I have the invasion squares
and blocked for the moment yeah if I go
f6 Bishop g6 is not really great but hmm
I don't want to want to lose the pawn oh
this thing is not really helping no but
played look d6 d6 first maybe I dunno it
was it was bad anyway but it's always
frustrating to lose again such a move
for just the tech support you cannot
defend it really
hmm so g6 maybe g6 and try to activate
the rupiah whites King is some slightly
endangered but this is something that
the computer is of course defending
I have to be careful you know to get my
my rook trapped at the end
okay so just attacking the spawn here
Knight f5 King III year leads nowhere
Jim when they have three it simply
simply well posted Jim protects the
weakness and there is no way forward for
me yeah my five come on okay resigned
stunning one more come on one more
I should really get one winning let's
see if I can manage one win
I was pretty dominating in some games
but I couldn't really finish the the
computer off it's of course always
defending very very very very well
so this London system and not the most
ambitious of openings but it's not such
a bad choice against the computer I
think leading to relatively
straightforward positions that are not
so difficult to play for a human so F
for one night of three I guess a form
keeping this under control
mmm
yeah D for might be a mafia
we should see to deform more okay so I
don't like to give up the push-up but
what about the quick gift I know the
computer should actually not allow it
uterus calculates calculation but I
cannot take it
oh come on I just take it and and see if
it works I mean it's a bit ridiculous
against the computer in a way but I
really didn't see her how are the comp
defends night fire for what exactly
wind you for maybe maybe 93 ends and
then check or so yeah night is sick as a
double check though 96 double check it's
not a double check and it's not a double
check what exactly am i doing no I had a
total loosen ation there okay so I've
just blundered the Queen yeah let's
let's wait I want to look at this just
for a moment let me can press analyze
right I just want to look at it briefly
is it really if I go to h4 for Queen
eight seven this is and it's not even a
maid threat right tweenage seventh king
f6 yeah so okay it's a little bit silly
to try the sacrifice against the comp
because it should prevent it but I was
for some reason thinking it's a double
check of course it's not okay so a match
against the comp again I hope you
enjoyed it it is really difficult to
play the machine even if it's not the
strongest comp ever it's still pose
difficult problems okay thanks for
watching